there's got to be a reason that he would
as you say
break up with the texas we don't we
don't go together no more
all right he breaks up with the texans
he describes himself as an athlete
he does not knock down a bunch of
stories
look it wouldn't be his his his uh
new new head coach for now david culley
and his new general manager for now nick
casario never would have had to
mention the trade rumors if deshawn
watson
had knocked him down but he never
knocked him down
like you could say it's easy for desean
watson to go to anybody
and say go to peter king mike florio
hey just you didn't hear this from me
sources
just just put out there trust me watson
thinks trade rumors are bogus so it's
not it's not
bogus so the rumors are out there and
all this stuff you put all the
circumstantial evidence together
i don't know if his agent right now is
is helping
i don't know if that helps maybe what do
you mean yeah okay oh well
i i talk with him often and i like a lot
of stuff out here
that's not true just let it don't go
don't go around like knocking down
individual reports
there's only one report for you to knock
down and that is but he pulled his name
john watson wants to be traded
when he pulled it but i mean but i got
but i hear you
he didn't knock down the the jets or the
dolphins or who his preferred team is
and all that kind of stuff
but when you say david mullighetto told
the texans this
like hold on player like you can't be
putting my [ __ ] like why my name coming
out
like i didn't do that if if it's
patently false
you understand what i'm saying like yeah
i i i
disagree with you on that point like i
don't mind david
getting his hands dirty when somebody
attributed
this move directly to him by name
yeah you also have to know you also have
to know who who the source is
i mean this is like dan sileo that's
what he does he kind of
is out there he kind of throws i don't
know if you're familiar with
some of the stuff that he's done but
he's just kind of like yeah
he'll he'll take some chances he'll
he'll get a little aggressive he'll
he'll he'll throw stuff out there
see what sticks gotcha um and
then also but this is a bigger point to
me with the texans after watching
you know what happened this weekend with
jared goff and i know how excited you
are jared goff matthew stafford
and you look at that you look at all you
see these reports mike
what teams are willing to give for
matthew stafford
and i'm not saying stafford's a bum it's
not a bum
i want to get back into that with you
later yeah yeah but
just to we i don't want to get into the
specifics of what teams offered what i'm
saying is
for the as it relates to the texans
you've got to realize it's a seller's
market out there player it's a it's a
seller's market
and to that's why i was just so one of
the reasons i was just so annoyed with
them on friday with this whole approach
we have no interest in trading the
player and we got to do this and he's
coming back here
he doesn't want you he doesn't want you
you need to get on the phone he's not
that into you he's just
that's right get on the phone and start
considering all the capital that teams
are able to offer
you you had carolina panthers offering
the number eight pick picking the draft
yeah teams offering multiple picks and
hey
let's check back in for matthew stafford
who's a good player i can call him a
really good player
yeah but watson's a great player go out
there and get that package and and uh
and just be done with
the situation so john mcclane from the
houston chronicle again who's
plugged in as any uh reporter is with
his uh with his hometown team
um remember i told you a couple of weeks
ago or even
y'all running it might have been last
week he had come off of the texans
aren't trading him
to if they traded changed that and then
changed that tune a little bit didn't he
well but he follow up with he followed
up with it in the aftermath of the
matthew stafford
trade um we have the
thank you the rams lions trade will have
nothing to do with the watson trade
the texans do it they'll want two ones
two twos and two young defensive
starters absolutely
kidding watson 25 under contract great
qb
team leader beloved by fans pillow their
community start with the jets
that's the second time john mclean has
pushed the jets by the way
um who we'll come to we'll talk about
the jets specifically
uh later but broadly speaking
that price tag that's a steal
that's a steal you think that's a steal
for different yeah
that's that's that's a steal and that's
settling if the texans trade the show
are offering deshawn watson for two ones
two twos and two young defensive
starters
not stars starters what do i sign
what do i sign of course i do that
every day and twice on sundays of course
i do that trade
two first two seconds i'm just you know
what because what i'm doing is
you know it's what we do it's what we do
it's like what is it
what does that mean so it's not really
two first for a team
team is really giving up one first
because you would use your first round
your 2021 you use your pick
on another player watson that player is
now designed
it's now desean watson i look at all
four of those pics in that vein
like where where where i'm tracking my
draft on my little board in my office
first round picking 21 desean watson
second round picking 21 desean watson
okay
great first round picking 22 deshawn
watson second one picking twenty two
sean watson cool
no problem i'm happy with that how about
those two stars
how about those two starters though
about two starting players
you don't care about some other ones
possible
see i can i can i raise a can i raise a
point
here please be my guest
that i just
i don't i don't hear this i don't hear
this often which could mean
it's brilliant it's crazy right right
um so deshaun watch i brought up
last week that he signed his contract in
september
he just signed the contract in september
that it was just a few months ago he
signed his contract with the houston
texans in september
and said how much he loved the the the
area and the in the city yeah frank the
whole thing
yeah but that's not what gets my
attention what gets my attention is
you're talking about giving in that
scenario you're talking about giving up
a half dozen players
for a quarterback who had a great season
and his team
won four games you're giving up
more players than you get in exchange
for wins
so you have to wonder how much
i keep hearing the thing that the price
keeps going up and up and up
and i think at some point you got to say
well wait a minute you you wouldn't
trade
if you make that deal what you're saying
is you would trade deshaun watson for
pretty much for anything
like that the number's got to be i would
give i would oh you wouldn't or i'd say
you would give up anything is a better
way of saying it
because if you if you if you're saying
oh yeah that's a steal
six players if if if the price is eight
to you if you're the jets and they say
we need three ones
we need three twos and we need two
players do you say
do it like when do you say all right
here's a guy who has been a
really terrific player for the houston
texans
but we're not talking about he's we're
not talking about the home still
we're not talking about that close oh
yes he is yes he's very close to patrick
mahomes
you know the difference you know the
difference between deshawn watson and
patrick holmes
you want to want to here's the
difference between the sean watson and
patrick holmes
one guy ended up in kansas city the
other guy ended up in houston
that's it that's the difference between
those two quarterbacks
it separates you from the rest of the
pack we saw the difference that brady
going to tampa made we see the
difference that my homes make makes
weekend and week out
it separates you from the rest of the
pack now some organizations are so
dysfunctional
houston that it does you can have
a historic season by your quarterback
and as j.j watt said
waste a year of his prime because the
rest of the organization is is so
messed up my fear
is that organizations like the jets
are going to overthink themselves out of
an opportunity
to set their organization on a course to
greatness
going back to the conversation we just
had no you can't overpay for desean
watson
and i want to hear oh but what about oh
wow two
first of all they have four ones in the
next two drafts
courtesy of the
jabal adams trade to seattle yeah but
they don't want to be less
need they don't want to be left homie
but here's the thing about the jets
here's the thing about the jets
as opposed to the rams who didn't have a
first round pick to give this year
the jets have so many picks until they
won't feel
it the same way other teams will feel it
okay number one number two michael you
can't
you i believe you get what you pay for
man i believe in life you get what you
pay for i believe that i agree with that
you have
things i agree there are certain things
whether it's a house
whether it's a car if you're fortunate
enough to have it
and you get it you're like oh okay i
know where my money goes
okay uh you know what you're just
teaching investment
you you teaching but you know what you
can also do
like first of all why am i why why are
the two people
who ain't in control of money talking
about money talking about money yeah
they're like
you're like i'm talking to you you you
ain't in control of the money and not
the boss i got the boss on me all right
but listen
you can still overpay for a house you
can overpay for a car you can't yes you
can but if you're
okay okay but based on based on who's
evaluation
okay i'll just i'll simplify it if it
ain't tricking if you got it
it ain't tricking if you got it and if
you
got it and then you get the house the
car or in this case the future hall of
fame quarterback don't nobody give a
damn about the first round picks it took
to get it okay
and here's the other thing you're
guaranteed you're assuming
you're assuming that yeah there's a
reason why sam darnold was the third
pick in the draft what does that have to
do with anything
and listen michael just for for purposes
of consistency
when we were talking early in the season
when the jets look like they were in a
position to get the number one pick
i was advocating for supporting sam
darnold yeah
by drafting painting sewell out of
oregon
exactly so i understand the logic but
this is why
without over thinking that's why i go
into overthinking five
because as much as we think trevor
lawrence is a second coming
we already know what desean watson is we
already
know what deshaun watson yeah well yeah
let's go back to that and trevor
lawrence would be
lucky if he grew up to be desean watson
so if you're the jets michael
you have an opportunity to solidify
this position like it hasn't been
solidified
in your franchise is history he's better
than john
throwing up chad pennington he's better
than broadway joe
the moment the moment he's on the roster
he's better than broadway joe
so i'm saying michael you you're
assuming if you're the jets
that you can not only hit on all these
draft picks
but that sam darnold you're guessing
that he's better than he's shown
and even if he's better than he's shown
unto adam gates it doesn't mean he's
sean watson
michael is a no-brainer bruh i'm sorry
it's a no-brainer it's a no-brainer
it's a no-brainer pony up we need to go
back to it but let's go back to
something cause i
i'm still aggrieved i'm still
concerned about something you said a few
minutes ago
and you said the only difference let me
see if i can just like quote you
accurately
for yourself and say that this one off
top of my head that's what i heard you
say
only difference between you know hey
michael you know the difference between
deshaun watson and patrick for holmes is
one was drafted by kansas city and one
was drafted by houston that's what you
said right you said that
a lot of people said though yeah that's
what i said yeah that's what i said you
said it yes that's exactly what i said
that's exactly what i said there's only
it's a
one seat car the car is a one seater
and if you're gonna say patrick mahomes
is the best quarterback in the league
we're not this is not interchangeable
you can't take patrick mahomes out
then drop somebody else in there and be
like oh
no no no i'm saying i'm saying all right
that the most accurate quarterback in
nfl history
look it up i know like
a barely like i think just that that
is the exact reporter or not the 30 yeah
sure
was like 67 one
nine or hey 67 what was it 68
is that what it was amazing
whatever it was oh yeah there used to be
a show called numbers of a lot of ones
you should love that [ __ ]
you still love it um he
i'm not saying look he hasn't done what
patrick holmes has done
like it's not he he doesn't have patrick
no no but i'm saying michael it's
circumcision okay michael
[Laughter]
no okay if that's fine you could laugh
you could like that's fine that's fine
you can laugh
i'm sure you're not the only one
laughing watching this right now and
that's fine that's okay
geniuses no problem michael you said
you're misunderstood now
you know i got nowhere misunderstood
okay i'll make it personal i'll make it
personal
i will take the pepsi challenge any day
of the week
when it comes to this show we're
streaming on peacock
if we like so somebody else who's on
a bigger platform a bigger network
uh on network television or or
a standard cable television i don't make
them better than us
i don't make them better that's correct
they just have more resources
they just been around longer they just
got more people aware of them that don't
make them
ain't nobody better than me at this
present company excluded nobody anybody
better than me and what i do
i don't judge it by twitter followers or
judging by you know i never let a statue
tell me no
tell me how nice i am there you go thank
you thank you okay shout out
to anybody better than me at this i take
the pepsi challenge with anybody
so likewise if you look at what desean
watson has done
with bill o'brien as his head coach but
they got the same platform
they got the same platform no no no no
no no it's the same thing they're
playing the same length lately
they say ballpark and ain't the same
sport they're playing us
i'm sorry you ain't gonna tell like
desean white said okay
if petrol holmes is better than sean
watson i'll meet you here it ain't by
much
and who and anyone if they traded places
it goes back to the moreno montana
argument which is without if they traded
places
and desean watson were in kansas city
and patrick mahomes were in houston how
would it go
i don't know we don't know but i
guarantee you kansas city will be right
where they are
same as they are with patrick mahomes
he's not getting shoulders above desean
watson
okay head and shoulders are strong
because you know we're talking about a
guy who did have a great season deshaun
watts i'm talking about
so head and shoulders is almost
disrespectful now that would get to the
point where i'm calling deshawn watson a
bum
and i don't believe that i do think he
is a top five quarterback but i think
the difference between one and five
is significant though maybe the
difference between one and three whoever
number three is
is it aaron rodgers uh you know who is
it
who do you think that that third best
quarterback in the league is
i don't know but i think patrick mahomes
uh just does incre he does things that
other people can't do
and that's why he's the best he does
things that other quarterbacks cannot do
he makes throws
uh no argument that they can't they
cannot make he
he's special so is the other guy yeah
but
all quarterbacks this is like again
philosophical conversation
they're all to some extent a result of
their surroundings the greatest of all
time
we know we cannot separate brady's
success
from the environment that he that he
achieved it in so
i'm not disrespecting patrick hall i'm
not saying patrick holmes ain't that
dude
i'm saying it helps city's got andy reid
and travis kelsey
and tyree kill and at defense
and eric the enemy it helps oh it needs
to say oh and that's not just
all of them all the great ones terry
bradshaw in pittsburgh montana and san
francisco
i'm only stating that and it and
passionately
if you are a team then that like the
jets
and you have a boundary of picks for you
to sit up here and say
that price tag is too high okay well
you got an opportunity to move into the
penthouse you don't want to pay the rent
you're also
we'll talk about this but you guys you
got to be able to build a team around
you got to have an environment they can
still
do that but it makes everybody else look
that much better when you got him on the
team